you know what might be the best way to
travel to the other side of the world
by drilling your way right through the
planet
this would be the journey of a lifetime
if you don't mind riding through molten
rock and
brushing pressure what would you see
along the way how long would this
journey through earth take and
how would a gravity train keep you alive
the heat is on and you're under all
sorts of pressure
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you drilled a hole through earth
imagine going from argentina to china in
less than an hour
all you need is a hole straight through
the earth
but drilling this hole would be the
hardest part of the endeavor
you could just handle it super villain
style and fire a laser at earth
but today we'll be taking a trip through
the biggest hole we've drilled
in the history of our planet sit tight
because
this is gonna be one heck of a ride
the first thing you'd need to do would
be to drill the deepest hole
humanity has ever imagined
we've already drilled holes through the
earth on what if so
you know what to do first you'd need a
really big drill and
it would take a few years to complete
this project
you'd be working in enormous heat and
pressure
and it would increase the closer you get
to earth's
center but when the hole is finished
you'd have your very own gravity tunnel
a gateway between one side of the earth
and the other
i'll explain how it would work in a
moment
next you'd need to find yourself a comfy
vehicle
to get you through the earth if you just
jumped into the
depths of the earth you'd burn to a
crisp
and crushed into a pancake so
hop on the gravity train this train
would accelerate
using only the force of gravity and it
would protect you from the searing heat
and extreme pressure the first leg of
the journey would take you through
earth's crust depending on where you
begin your trip
the crust can be five to seventy
kilometers thick
and amazingly it only makes up one
percent of the entire earth you'd start
your journey
feeling pretty carefree and at 20 meters
below the surface
you'd be at the same level as subways or
the paris catacombs
but let's go a little further down at
two and a half kilometers
you'd be at the same depth as the
deepest fossil
ever discovered and once you get to 3.6
kilometers
you'd be able to see the devil worm it's
the deepest living animal ever found
ah is it just me or is it getting hot
believe it or not some people are
working at this depth
the mpanen gold mine in south africa is
so far
down that the heat is an issue and
believe me you wouldn't enjoy the 60
degrees celsius temperature down here
then gravity would take you further down
at 8.8 kilometers below the earth's
surface
you'd have traveled further than the
height of mount everest
and at 11 kilometers underground you'd
be deeper
than the mariana trench at
12.26 kilometers you would reach
the same depth as the cola super deep
borehole
it's the deepest hole we've ever dug and
now
you'd really feel the intense pressure
on your body
at this step air pressure is 4 000 times
the pressure at sea level
as you approach the end of the first
part of this epic journey
you might get to see a plethora of gems
i'm talking about rubies sapphires and
emeralds
they could be valuable souvenirs if you
make it through
to the other side of the earth and at 40
kilometers down
part one of your voyage would be behind
you or
above you depending on how you see it
let's go onward to the second layer of
earth
the mantle most people think it has a
lava-like texture but
at this shallow depth relatively
speaking
it's rock solid only when you're deeper
will it start becoming
molten this would be the longest part of
your journey
that's because the mantle makes up an
impressive
84 percent of earth's volume
the mantle is about 2 900 kilometers
thick
you wouldn't see much inside it except
for
one dazzling exception at this depth
the enormous pressure and heat forms
diamonds they make their way to the
earth's surface
through volcanic activity and that's
where we humans find them but you are
lucky
and find them at their birthplace don't
be shy
grab a few as you arrive about
410 kilometers below the surface
things would start to get weird the
mantle's rock would be
molten hot but instead of it staying
in its melted state the mantle would
turn
hard that's because of the extreme
pressure
moving on to the bottom of the mantle a
mere 1 000 kilometers down
you would experience the force of mantle
blobs
these are supercharged plumes of hot
rock and
if they surface they would become
devastating
super volcanoes no need to say you'd
feel
extremely hot you'd be
almost halfway through the earth and
that must mean you're
approaching the outer core at depths of
3000 kilometers
the outer core is made of iron and
nickel
and boy would it be hot the temperatures
around you would range from
4 500 to 5500 degrees celsius
at 5 000 kilometers below the surface
you'd reach
the earth's inner core this giant
solid iron sphere has a mind-boggling
temperature of
5200 degrees celsius and the pressure
is a crushing 3.6
million times more than at sea level
let's hope your gravity train would be
up to the challenge at these extreme
temperatures and pressures
i didn't read the manual but i'm sure
you'll be just fine
finally you would make it to the halfway
point of your subterranean voyage
right at the center of earth the mass
would be equal in all directions and you
get to experience zero gravity
but remember that was just half the
journey
you'll have to do that all over again
but in reverse
to finish your trip this journey
would put you under a lot of pressure it
would make you hot
most likely uncomfortable and rich you
did collect the diamonds didn't you
now how long do you think it would take
to get from one side of the earth
to the other okay it's time i told you
more about the gravity tunnel
this is a theoretical passageway through
the earth or
simply a hole through the earth as i
like to call it if it's
created correctly you could get from one
side of the earth
to the other in about 42 minutes
using a gravity train but as i mentioned
before
traveling through the earth would be the
easy part
it's the drilling that would be hard
if we could engineer such a feat it
would revolutionize travel
and you'd have one short but epic
journey
but what if that hole through earth was
bigger what if earth were
shaped like a donut well
as always i'll leave that story for
another
what if